beaucoup de gens le considèrent comme le
plus grand acteur français vivant il
fêtera bientôt ses 50 ans de vie
professionnelle il commence le tournage
d'un nouveau film
il n'avait pas tourné depuis verdict le
film d'andré cayatte il accepte
difficilement qu'on vienne le voir
travailler et donne très rarement des
interviews
jean gabin puisqu'il s'agit de lui a
cependant accepté de recevoir à limbé
verini ne vous étonnez pas si gabin
bourgogne c'est son rôle préféré dans
une cabine de 747 reconstituée en studio
jean giraud tourner l'année sainte une
comédie policière qui aurait pu être
tragique puisqu'elle commence par une
prise d'otages
nos tâches pas comme les autres
d'ailleurs puisqu'il ya une fausse
duchesse danielle darrieux info prélat
jean gabin et infos abbé jean claude
brialy
lors de notre court entretien jean gabin
a bien voulu nous parler de sa passion
de son métier
le cinéma amitié je fais je le fais je
le sais le mieux possible et puis c'est
tout comme alors si c'est ça que vous
appelez la portion maintenant c'est de
la pression mais je le sais donc j'ai
toujours servi que j'essaye de bien
faire si vous dis pas qu'il est que ce
métier est une passion c'est qu'il le
fait avec passion qu'il n'a pas besoin
de le dire
eh bien ce n'est pas la première fois
que vous tournez avec jean gabin non
c'est la quatrième fois j'ai déjà tourné
avec jean la vérité sur bébé donge eu le
plaisir de 10 ans dans la nuit et c'est
la quatrième fois je suis heureuse comme
tout de retrouver jean et jean claude
brialy
les elders sont de grands grands amis on
a quand on a affaire à une énorme
fenêtre où on a toujours je parle pour
le public
le souhait de la voir le plus souvent
possible sur les sur les écrans et on
trouve que peut-être la table un petit
peu rare vu de très gentil mais la burj
support une énorme boulette et d'une
et puis ça lui pendait les sujets ce
très difficile de trouver les sujets
tournés les bons scénarios sont rares il
est vrai tous les grands acteurs en
réclame alors on comprend mieux les
silences de certains jean gabin qui a
tourné dans sa vie près de 100 films
dont une bonne vingtaine de
chefs-d'oeuvre déteste autant faire des
projets que de se pencher sur son passé
chaque film terminé est un film oublié
pour toujours oublié mes employés
terminé terminé on va pour revenir
dessus
un produit on va leur faire du bien en
marche mais pour je sais je sais vous
voyez c'est au cinéma comme dans la
chanson je sais qu'on sait jamais comme
dit loeb